people who are independent are heroes  victims are not heroes people who  overcame challenges are heroes not the  ones that constantly blame somebody and  feel helpless about themselves nothing  about that is attractive nothing about  being a victim is attractive there are  people who have experienced things that  are  you know actual victims but the concept  of victimhood mentality has spread  across america today where we're turning  them into heroes oh my gosh look what  happened to you i feel so sorry for you  and we all feel sorry for you as if  you're helpless if you can walk talk  speak read think smell taste all that  stuff you have the capability to do  something big with europe